- blk is pure, premium hydration.
blk is premium, you heard it here first.
- Premium alkaline water, it's pure,
it has 70 plus trace minerals, non-GMO.
- Maybe it's like from
the roots of a tree.
Maybe it's like dirt liquified.
- Tastes kinda like tasteless tea.
- My mind wants to make me think
that I'm drinking something not water.
But it tastes just like water.
- With a powerful
combination of electrolytes,
vital trace minerals, and
an alkaline pH of eight,
blk is pure, premium hydration.
I don't know what any of that stuff means.
- It's just water, it's just plain water.
- I like this.
- Wow, it's weird,
this blk water tastes
just like regular water.
Who woulda thought?
- I'm gonna try and see
if I know the difference
between regular water and blk water.
- Oh my gosh, I can't tell the difference.
- This one felt more like authentic,
so I'm gonna say the
one on my left is water
and the one on my right is blk water.
(bell ringing)
- Is this a prank?
Is it just both regular water?
- blk water.
(bell ringing)
- Oh, so I was right.
The minerals that are in here
are found in plants and soil
and they're highly nutritious.
Wow, look how smart I am.
I was like it's probably dirt water.
(record scratching)
But healthy.
- Doesn't taste like refreshing as water.
- They taste almost exactly the same.
At the end of the day
it tastes like water.
It doesn't look like
water, but it's water.
(upbeat music)